all right spider-man actually we are in
the building
I LP first look at these games and war
footage wow this thing looks absolutely
spectacular all ready
so first of all the back definitely
looks like a true open world as opposed
to gameplay hubs which is when I was a
little bit worried about animation looks
very fluid game game so far looks great
he's getting some some early looks at it
you know this was all the rage at the
Sony Playstation conference
and definitely one of the most
anticipated PlayStation titles going
obviously we all saw the trailer we saw
the bosses it looks spectacular than
what we saw
they're gonna suit
Oh
got a wet swingin
I like that real fluid
lags but like we got our first little
cutscene I remember this from the
initial demo so let's see how this joint
plan out
they love that little hundred-foot news
[Music]
what does he have a spot a sense is
actually incorporated you know
and also it will be interesting to see
if there's anything more than those kind
of preset combos door slam
[Music]
yeah other than that yeah so that there
you go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so let's absolutely here's my I want to
see the running animation and although I
was complaining earlier when I all did
up actually on e3 PlayStation Sony
Playstation and Conference of you that
was my only issue is I did like the
running animation seeing it in person
it's not as bad as I thought it was it
actually is okay so kognito might have
to relate that one
[Music]
will be almost assassin's creed's now
[Music]
get the city look at the skull look at
the draw distance and they they've
definitely captured a new essence you're
gonna mean you got that feel you gotta
look at the old man and a left-handed
Trade Center building that's New York
y'all y'all now from New York wouldn't
it said that's the New World Trade
Center in a bat so it looks like that's
his next objective and finally objective
line
[Music]
this looks really beautiful really fluid
I bumped his head though it was a small
bonus but that's the plan I did the game
that ADA gave all right so you got
another enemy situation going on
chorus fighting with one soul
[Music]
what the hell aggressive the AI gets
couldn't say as you go further on so
many earlier levels my lilo like just to
get play acclimated to what's going on
you know
[Music]
you
[Music]
so we have to look like a little
destructible islands even web-swing
without one hall one
yellow focus go along
[Music]
if air out that whole little mechanic
right there with the focus was in Sunny
Hill itself you'd afternoon and I'm
noticing ways
[Music]
the leg after the alleged sex or he is
not playing with smiling right now
city knobbly is tight so exciti
spider-man shenanigans
there you go oh really lays its
marketing laser
[Music]
[Music]
so we got our web slide in fact dodge
shoot webs they got ahold for caching or
[Music]
Oh
we
Oh Lauren thing okay
[Music]
I really like that mechanic though
[Music]
in that society about yet
[Music]
all right got that focus while fall to
see him get busy he said via Facebook
folks law by the way let's go watch that
sword dude or how he duels damn they got
spanked
[Music]
hopefully we can get it at understand my
way
oh you do not get hit with the bazooka
go okay now we get the shielded enemies
let's go
dorababu all right so you got press way
circle for the dodge move there we go
getting busy all you get busy get busy
there we go
[Music]
let's go let's go you ready let's go hmm
all right so we got the fist kite out so
we got it looks like we got confirmed
kingpin in the building because we have
to walk what's his name call me Fisk one
of them fists automatic action
[Music]
like I bagged up the enemies
like our bonus objectives also going on
in the game probably challenge most
things of that nature
it's absolutely stunning even when he's
standing still all right that's really
really good
[Music]
[Music]
little objectives like different colored
objectives based on where he has to go
game is not hand-holding you which is
what I like you know the main kind of
way to do things at your own pleasure
[Music]
all right so something 19 I mean it's
Alma robbery going on downtown all right
so it's kind of like you know
[Music]
live things going on it shouldn't kind
of deal with wanna climb level one which
is pretty cool
old oozes out here the streets is
private there we go
Spidey's all about using them some
barrels
me
see that dodge mechanic is gonna be
critical
maybe Webster or one more
the enemy's told war sure is to see what
the objective completed actually gets
you five minutes at demo
[Music]
right clam tokens all right so you got
some clamps I was a stop an armed
robbery
[Music]
look at the people bit funny
now apparently from what I've been told
like the people actually you know talk
to spider-man ask him to do stuff like
gotta be interactive so they're just not
like static all the time so I've got
some confirmation shot at the
PlayStation growing that one in a minute
but hey Spidey do XYZ or whatever
whatever so it kind of gives you that
feeling of you know
Interactive world the little mini gt
anything going on which is cool
so he's got to get his next objective
see that dodge mechanic is going to be
credible
[Music]
let me try to get out of it oh yah -
yeah Gibbs buddy no little ROK
now this works for me I remember the
initial demo almost like a car chase
kind of thing going off
again I'm sweaty morning
oh we lost on mass getting away
his body thinks getting the more foot as
the S
the Lord is good
all right
let's move there we go as Princess Pea
fall down like we got a shot
Spidey's doesn't seem interested in
trying to stop the old robber
it's okay you got other things you want
to do
Oh do it now he ain't catching that guy
a thousand meters away
Spidey's power Lord oh look look look
stylish oh oh you're not catching
robbers buddy fresh right now it's fresh
no cops shootout Bordeaux so it looks
like a lot of live interactive moments
you know as far as uh the city and stuff
itself very curious to see what would
have happily snuper's very true to see
what have happened if he would have
caught that are kind of like interactive
scene going on with over the robbers
hopefully they get it we get a little
dual we might all right
[Music]
600
what spy let's go hey we go let's go
stakeout hot ground
[Music]
one minute man let's see we can catch
him let's go to the sounds right time
[Music]
almost there can we catch him
all righty we in the building let's go
so now they're getting a raw horn spot
in the trademark over
Scarecrow in the building
cinematix of fantastic spelling with the
jokes
[Music]
Wow really looks good
like a seamless transition between sin
American game player
okay
Oh
so it looks like he's in a runnable
state at that point
[Music]
there you go smiling again I'm gonna
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
yes let's say you got to go through a
dodging mechanic use the barrels or any
other environment and then really get
them during that final state
[Music]
spider-man talking at all
[Music]
well has been sits buddy
oh wait no
[Music]
when I stole baby King fix you out
though
[Music]
like that I like getting kind of fakes
yeah
[Music]
checkpoints look a little forgiving this
is all right with me
[Music]
okay so here's ain't you know you got a
suit power they want you back okay
you gotta wait
[Music]
make sure you swing
[Music]
you gotta avoid that shockwave
Oh ain't looking good y'all right ain't
looking good there you go gotta stay
swinging keep that movement going that's
a mercy looking get healthy look good
[Music]
Spidy might be out of they are
[Music]
one last run one last check come on
[Music]
see if he could do it
[Music]
in
[Music]
Adam
[Music]
[Music]
now the issue is trying to do damage
while he's doing that day you know
one more should be loving one more face
this is the hard part right there
you start getting crazy
danam everybody let's go
or a stale gonna evil with the one leg
socket is stubborn
there you go
ha ha right there so close to the third
phase well that's it y'all 7/7 party was
uneven but we got it done September 7th
coming in stores checking out some what
you feel about the game man yeah dude
it's pretty cool yeah yeah yeah that'll
be definitely been in spite of me in
stores making Sonia first bro